all right monday edition of pft live
rolls around and what we've done in the
past on mondays it's the sunday surprise
we tried to go with something different
today we are going with something
different trying to we are chris
defining moments of week 17 that is our
draft for today and i have a question
what i just what occurred to me did you
wear that shirt on the show last night
did you no i didn't stop it i didn't
make sure all right all right good stop
it
yeah you keep trying that no i've
learned i learned the hard way okay not
to try to pull that off derek henry won
his second straight rushing title who
was the last player to lead the league
in rushing in back-to-back season
wow okay um
i i mean man you want to say i'm not
it's not an answer i mean i wanna my
mind goes right to adrian peterson
and
i think uh sir nope it's not or cj2k but
i would think it's i'm gonna go
ladainian tomlinson
oh
did you look at the did you cheat did
you cheat i don't cheat ever never all
right um sure this is this just in
i'm a historian like i've told you a
million times all right go ahead and get
the first pick go ahead in all honesty i
saw the stat somewhere the last week or
so on tv somewhere where they talked
about back to back rushing leaders and
that's where i got it from um and this
mind is like a steel trap it just once
you get it in there it's there okay
defining moment for me i'm going to go
to
the los angeles rams arizona cardinals
football game seven five straddler in a
quarterback
cardinals driving down before the half
they're in french field goal territory
straveler throws a ball down the seam
and
oh wait there's no receiver there and
troy hill picks it off and returns it
for a 84-yard pick six that to me one of
the defining moments of sunday where it
was a defensive battle with two
quarterbacks to that point
wolford was the only one who had done
something done dumb with his first pick
of the day on his first throw of the day
and then that was hey we got a young
quarterback who's inexperienced too look
what he can do oh he'll give you a free
seven points that changed the game and
really the rams never relinquish the
power the momentum from the game from
there on out
i gotta go back to what we spent the
first half hour of the show talking
about because i think the defining
moment of the day and the moment that
will resonate into today and possibly
beyond is the benching of jalen hurts
that that is the moment that washington
clinched the nfc east and the giants
were able to get salty about what the
eagles were trying to pull and whatever
the reason whatever the layers whatever
the levels that's the moment when i
think back to the 17th sunday of the
2020 season the one thing that's going
to stand out is the decision of the
eagles to pull jalen hurts out of a
close game and concede
to washington and take the higher pick
at number six in round one versus number
nine that's the one thing i'll never be
able to forget
man i know that's it's uh it's a killer
still i i really couldn't even believe
and you see fletcher cox that's pretty
good though
i love it um but i i will say like
watching it
it was as jarring as you know ever is it
just being like oh my gosh they're
intentionally trying to lose it's the
first time ever
that i really felt that way watching an
nfl football game you know and again
like i wasn't watching that 2014 bucks
game last game of the year so i just it
was jarring i guess because it was
sunday night football and the
implications but uh something else it's
one of those things i think i'll never
forget just how you kind of felt at that
moment
um all right my next one uh i'm gonna go
to the seattle game we haven't talked
about them yet but you talk about a
sunday defining moment well it doesn't
have to do with russell wilson it has to
do with the defense and benson miowa
getting the strip sack fumble on cj
beathard late in the football game
seahawks finally go up in the football
game they had been struggling now
they're up 19 to 16 after a long drive
and a great throw touchdown pass by
russell wilson they get to strip sack
and then a few plays later score a
touchdown to go up by 10 points to where
to me that was ball game seattle who had
struggled all day long and
mike i mean it's crazy with seattle it
was all about their offense the first 10
weeks of the year
and now it's the offense is kind of
struggling and it's all about russell
making plays and the defense is the most
consistent thing they got going the
defense other than the rams has been the
best defense in football over the last
five or six weeks phenomenal i can't
believe the transformation of the team
all together
and you know the seahawks were playing
in that window at the same time the
saints were at carolina and the packers
were at chicago and there were different
ways the dominoes could fall for any of
the three teams to be the number one
seed and early on it wasn't clear how it
was gonna work out and there was just
kind of a sense or the packers actually
gonna blow their shot to have home field
advantage in the division around and if
they win there the the championship
round and then and then i'm surprised
i'm taking this and not you then came
the moment
oh aaron rodgers to marquez
scantling for 72 yards the catch and run
that was the moment where it's like okay
okay the bears
no no it's fun for a little while right
but the packers are gonna win this game
and the packers are gonna nail down the
one seed and the road to the super bowl
is going through lambeau field which
will have a huge influence on who gets
there and raises considerably the
chances it'll be the packers
representing the nfc chris yeah
can't disagree with that i mean it's
hard i mean rogers and green bay up in
green bay in those elements
uh they're they're just there's
something about it and of course he just
he it just doesn't matter just like you
see in chicago last night it just
doesn't matter how cold how windy it is
it doesn't matter the guy has hands like
a caveman okay i've shook his hands his
fingers are 12 inches long and he can
just grab the ball and rip it through
the air any way he wants he's just he's
one of the most gifted throwers we've
ever seen and that's why they're going
to be tough to beat up in green bay all
right um i haven't given my g-men any
love i got to give my g-men some love
joe judge daniel jones giants way to
fight wait is is the defining moment
when the guy recovered the fumble with
his butt well hey it might be i mean yes
that was that was a defining moment it
was kind of like the giants you're in a
nutshell right there i was gonna go to
the what happened just before that
though and andy dalton throwing the
interception in the end zone on third
down where yeah they were going down
trying to take a lead in the football
game the giants defense as it did for
the most part of the day
came through in a big situation got
pressure on dalton forced him to throw
an interception xavier mckinney
intercepts it but the giants just a lot
of credit for them for perseverance all
year yesterday they really controlled
that football game through and through
i mean daniel jones and wayne gallman
they had the
the drop handoff early in the game that
gave the cowboys a short field evan
ingram had a ball that went right
through his two hands that gave the
cowboys another drive for a touchdown
but either way give them a lot of credit
for fighting in a big game and and
beating the cowboys
i think the defining moment of this
draft is your failure to take any moment
that was truly a defining moment for
sunday but that's okay it's your
prerogative i'm not i'm not being
critical well why why was the rams pick
six not a defining moment i don't
understand why was the story because
nobody's gonna nobody cares because
nobody care who's gonna how's that gonna
be remembered how's that gonna resonate
what does that define it defines a
meaningless game that's that's why well
i'm sorry i was put up to that well i
mean it defines what the okay
i don't know if it was meaningless i
mean it wasn't meaningless at the time
maybe maybe the guy that gave you that
idea to say that should come up with a
better draft and do his job the next
time maybe that's what he should do all
right the last one for me and i let it
just hang there and i i was going i
thought by now i'd be down to isaiah
mckenzie's 84 yard touchdown on a punt
return if you haven't seen it go watch
it he stops he starts he zigs his eggs
and that was the moment that that game
was over but i'm gonna go with the
cleveland browns third and one
it's 24-22 they need one play and with
the browns you never quite know that you
can count on them to make one play they
did student body right with baker
mayfield he slides for the first down he
gets up with the emphatic first down
indication and that was the moment that
18 years of pent-up frustration in
cleveland
finally had come to fruition even though
there were only 11 870 fans there they
got to enjoy it and the browns fans
everywhere got to enjoy it and they have
suffered and they deserved so much
better than what they've gotten so
uh yeah i left it there for you through
through two rounds and you didn't take
it chris i i i yeah okay great whoopty
do i like mine better okay great uh but
either way and then the browns they're
on sidekick recovery right i mean that
was scary in itself they kind of had a
giants type fumble recovery where the
guy like recovered it with his butt and
it was so you were like oh my gosh the
steelers gonna recover this and you're
just thinking is cleveland totally
jinxed but uh good thing they got it and
uh i resent you attacking my defining
moments i really do
oh that's fine uh but and and look it it
we really do need to
you know if you're a fan of any other
team but the browns
and and i guess there are others that
have had extended stretches but for the
most part you know people lock on to
teams that are
are successful that aren't dysfunctional
that get to the playoffs every other
year every year three out of four five
out of six whatever it may be
to go 18 years
without playing a single playoff game
think about that it's a generation yeah
and i feel bad for the browns because i
have to go back to pittsburgh that's
where they played a playoff game yeah
the last time they were in 2002 the only
playoff game of the resurrected browns
the team that that moved to baltimore in
1995 became the ravens and then got back
into the nfl in 1999 96 is when they
moved for the 96 season but they got
back in 1999 one playoff berth before
this year
it i wish they didn't have to play the
steelers
um but but you know what if they go and
they beat the steelers that'll make that
a defining moment wild card weekend yeah
no you're right i mean
i'm with you it's a little bit like i
wish they weren't going to play each
other but
it is going to be intense it always is
extra intense when you had to play the
team the week before it's going to be
personal and yeah cleveland if they
could win this one it'll be it'll mean
more than the extra wild card win
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports